[Music]
do
[Music]
hello i'm rob matheson and this is
counting the cost on al jazeera your
weekly look at the world of business and
economics this week what's the price of
rebuilding ukraine and who are going to
be the real winners
also this week almost 830 million people
around the world went hungry in 2021 and
that number is rising why is the world
moving backwards as it tries to
eliminate hunger and malnutrition
plus zimbabwe's currency crisis is
getting deeper why have people lost
confidence in banks and the economy
[Music]
ukraine's president vladimir zelensky
says he thinks it's going to cost
three-quarters of a trillion dollars to
rebuild his country after the war now
even as the fighting continues western
leaders from dozens of nations
international organizations and the
private sector have been talking about
how to rebuild ukraine many say ukraine
needs another marshall plan that was a
huge economic rescue deal that was
devised by the us to rebuild europe
after world war ii now the challenge of
rebuilding a nation after a conflict is
complex businesses and politicians have
a crucial role to play billions of
dollars are at stake researchers at the
world economic forum say private
investors going into a war-torn country
need a positive business case for
investing in unstable conflict-ridden
places maybe looking for a functioning
state with working institutions able to
give sustainable investment
investors often have skills and
experiences that can support governments
shattered by fragility and conflict
there would need to be opportunities for
public-private partnerships to
kick-start growth and work together
citizens and local businesses must be
part of the plans and backers from
outside can help foster transparent and
efficient money management practices
well joining us from stockholm is
torbjorn beckham he's the director of
the stockholm institute of transition
economics and he's also a board member
of the kiev school of economics so thank
you very much indeed for being with us
so the world economic forum has produced
a long list of requirements that
investors would need to be in place
before they would move into a country
like ukraine to start rebuilding that's
a long list to take off isn't it how
tough is that going to be
well it's going to be tough for ukraine
as for any other countries that comes
out to a situation like this obviously
and i think we have to remember all of
these lists have to start with some
level of security in ukraine so some
sort of end to the aggression from
russia needs to be the starting point
for most of these investments to come i
would think
rebuilding ukraine um makes for great
publicity
but politicians are likely to be using
taxpayers money private investors are
going to be looking to make some sort of
profit
in terms of the practicality of doing
something like this going on past
experience
how likely is it that ukraine is
actually going to get the rebuilding
support that it believes that it needs
well it's going to require a lot of
strong reform efforts i think the first
step has already been taken with the eu
accession process getting off the ground
pretty
pretty well the last couple of weeks we
also have very strong support from
international leaders that will help
ukraine to move along on that path but
of course there's a lot of of issues to
be dealt with on on the road ahead in
terms of the actual investment itself
how could companies and indeed
governments because as i say they're
using taxpayers money be guaranteed that
the money that they're investing is
actually going to be used in the
projects that they believe it is going
to be we have seen historically in
places like afghanistan and iraq and and
other crisis hit areas in the past where
the amount of money that's invested
isn't actually the amount of money that
gets on the ground is there a facility
for creating some sort of guarantee
well i think
rebuilding some of the institutions that
that deal with corruption and rule of
law
is already on on the short list of
things and priority lists of things to
do for the ukrainian government and i
think this will be key to this i also
think we have to remember that ukraine
is a democratic country that i think has
become much more united
in this war so i think there will be a
much more
strong sense of common purpose and
direction in the whole country
compared to some of the cases you just
mentioned where it was much more
fractionalized in terms of the domestic
politics so in that sense i think
ukraine uh has has better hopes of of
making this a successful rebuilding
process one of the things that we've
seen in the past when there's been
investment like this is that companies
countries go in
on the stipulation that any work and
that is done within the country actually
goes to companies within those countries
so essentially the money becomes a cycle
it goes into those companies but it then
goes back to the original um
the original country
who do you think are going to be the
financial winners out of any rebuilding
plan for ukraine
well i mean that that's hard to discuss
i guess but i mean we i think the
international community has a strong
common interest to make sure that the
winners of this is going to be the
people of ukraine and not our specific
companies that that we want to support
i mean there's a long history of of
talking about untied aid for example
where we do not support our individual
countries from let's say sweden or the
uk or or or wherever the country
money is coming from so i think this
will also be important here
so the international community needs to
do its homework on governance and
anti-corruption as well as the ukrainian
side
is there any mechanism within say
i don't know the world bank for example
any global mechanism that could oversee
the level of investment and and the
money that is going into ukraine to try
to keep track of what is being put in
place
well i mean you're mentioning the world
bank which of course is an important
international player i think giving the
eu accession process i think the eu
needs to be very heavily involved in
this
fondue lion has said that they're
setting up a platform to coordinate
donors
so i think something like that will be
needed to to really help ukraine
coordinate the outside world and make
sure that these issues of transparency
and anti-corruption is
is dealt with properly there has been a
lot of discussion about whether or not
russia should be made to pay for some of
the rebuilding process how likely do you
think that is and how would you enforce
it i think there is plenty of of russian
assets that are ceased outside of
russia's border but of course there will
be probably very long legal processes to
to make a transfer of those assets to
to ukraine so i'm
in terms of times horizon i'm not sure
when when that money could be made
available to ukraine but it's going to
take a lot of legal processing i'm sure
part of the conflict has seen a lot of
damage done to
small and medium businesses within
ukraine and as is commonly said small
and medium businesses are often a
driving force for for any country's
economy
what is the risk do you think that the
the projects they're going to the
rebuilding projects that are going to
happen in ukraine are going to be
on the larger scale and the small and
medium business sector is going to to
miss out
well i think it would be quite natural
if small and medium-sized enterprises
become
subcontractors to a lot of these
processes so i i really don't see that
as something for them to miss out on but
i mean it's also going to depend on what
kind of skills they have in those
businesses so maybe
part of the solution will be
retraining some of the people that have
been working in in other sectors in the
past to be part of the reconstruction
process
becca is director of the stockholm
institute of transition economics so we
appreciate your time thank you very much
indeed thank you
the united nations says nearly 830
million people around the world went
hungry in 2021 and that number is set to
rise this year in low-income countries
where agriculture is key to the economy
livelihoods have been affected by the
impact from covert 19 and rising global
inflation let's look at syria for
example where wheat is an essential crop
in a deteriorating economy that many
depend on bread as their main source of
food
our correspondent zena cotter explains
how farmers in the northwest who are
struggling with drought and high
production costs are becoming
increasingly dependent on imports of
grain
before the uprising in 2011 syria was
able to feed itself
but years of war and now a severe
drought has made this nation a net
importer of wheat
over the past two to three years
the whole country has been hit by a
crippling drought
that its impacts are felt mostly in the
northeast which is traditionally the
bread basket of the country
let alone areas that are in the
northwest of the country or regime held
areas
the rise in global prices sparked by
russia's invasion of ukraine is
threatening food supplies to many people
in syria the country is among the 10
most food insecure nations in the world
12 million people struggle to get enough
food many of them live in the opposition
controlled north
we have limited incomes and yet we have
to rely on expensive imported wheat
because much of the land in this region
is mountainous we can't grow much wheat
and lands where wheat can be grown are
not accessible vast areas were set on
fire by government forces during the
conflict and irrigation channels were
destroyed and even though there is now
less violence front lines still exist
we are close to the regime positions
many people can't reach their land
because it is dangerous humanitarian
organizations as well as the local
authorities are helping farmers to
produce more food but it's costly to
plant crops so is transporting the
harvest due to high fuel prices
fuel is also needed to pump groundwater
to make up for what is being described
as syria's worst drought in 70 years
in the opposition held area in the north
production won't be enough
this year 30 000 hectares were
cultivated but the low rainfall and high
production costs hurt farmers a ton of
wheat costs 450 dollars we will have to
import more than 30 000 tons this year
the average annual amount of wheat
production before the war was 3.7
million tons this declined to 1.8
million tons between 2015 and 2019.
harvests are shrinking and farmers are
fighting to survive and with more than
half of syria's people already hungry
the agricultural crisis couldn't come at
a worse time
al jazeera
well cindy holloman is a senior
economist of food security and nutrition
in the food and agriculture organization
of the united nations she's joining us
now
from rome thank you very much indeed for
being with us what is driving food
insecurity
there's a there's about four major
drivers that we've been analyzing that
um is leading to this uptick in hunger
that we're observing um one is conflict
so conflicts are becoming more
protracted and and complex and then we
have new conflicts like the war were in
ukraine
a big one also is climate extremes
climate variability
heat heat extreme heat
flooding storms this extreme climate
weather is also creating havoc in terms
of production
prices and that's a big driver in terms
of food insecurity and hunger and then
the third one which is actually more
growing in prominence is the economic
slowdowns and shocks
whether it's caused by the covet
pandemic and the measures put in place
which disrupts supply chains
people lose their incomes
so these economic shocks really create a
big problem for people to access food
so those are the three
big drivers and then the other one
that's very important is inequality
so we see that
while poverty has been going down in the
last
few years
high income equality or inequality in
terms of access to services like health
or
um
basic um services in terms of sanitation
and and everything
or is unequal so this high inequality is
also a big driver behind food insecurity
so when you get these shocks like
an economic shock of economic downturn a
market price increase
where there's countries that have high
inequality we see that the effects are
much greater
what are the countries around the world
that are being hit hardest by this
well i think you know
the covet pandemic
we saw um you know the largest global
recession that we've seen in a long time
and so we saw hunger increase and food
insecurity increased in every country
around the world
so that was quite a major shock if we
look at the number of people that are
hungry
um our latest estimates show that since
2019 before the koben pandemic 150
million more people are hungry
so it did affect every country around
the world
however we do see hungers increasing
faster in africa um the the percent
increase is the higher
this isn't just about low-income
countries have you been talking about
this is hitting all parts of the world
are there any areas which have surprised
you which you wouldn't normally expect
to have been affected by this that have
actually been had it had an impact
well i think you know for for um the
results were seen you know everybody
expects you know the bad news about
africa
um it is got the fastest growing number
of people that are hungry
it has got droughts it's got conflict
it's got economic shocks
um you know high levels of inequality
i think that's kind of expected but i
think what's unexpected is the high
levels of
food insecurity increasing in latin
america
so if we look at latin america the
increases has been doubling in terms of
food insecurity since 2015.
we also see um you know rising levels of
obesity and overweight which is also a
very big problem in terms of
malnutrition it's a it's a part of
of um
nutrition that's critical for people's
productivity for their for their health
um and we see that increasing around the
world
and that's related to the high cost of
of nutritious foods
if i understand it correctly the
worldwide financial support for farmers
is about 630 billion us dollars and the
un
has said that a lot of that doesn't even
get as far as the farmers what kind of
impact does that have and and why is
that happening if you look at the
support the 630 billion most of it goes
toward
trade barriers price incentives
and it's very focused on
staple crops dairies and meat while
vegetables and fruits and more healthier
items are also
penalized or even discouraged from
production so we are also calling for a
re-look at how governments are spending
their money
a healthy diet is five times more
expensive than a basic energy diet on
staples cindy holloman we really
appreciate you being with us and al
jazeera thank you very much indeed
thank you
zimbabwe is battling hyper inflation
which has led to a loss of public
confidence in banks and conventional
pension systems many are now looking for
safer ways to protect their investments
adam matassa reports from norton where
cattle have become a safer option than
the local currency
with inflation nearly reaching 192
in june
and zimbabwe's dollar fast losing its
value investing in cattle has become a
safer option for some people here than
the local currency an investment they
can see and trust
[Music]
they obviously choose how many units
they want to to invest in
it's all zimbabwe dollar related
investment
there's 13 000 units available for
investment
one unit is equal to 100 kgs of live
cattle
the expectation is that the price the
value of the cattle appreciates in time
unlike zimbabwe's dollar and if clients
want to get paid out their investments
are valued and they get their cash back
for people in zimbabwe and other african
nations catholic have long been a source
of wealth in many rural areas they are
used as currency to pay school fees now
similar schemes are being offered to
people in urban areas
like any investment there are risks
animals can get sick and die from
drought and diseases but there are also
ways to increase their potential
when they drop their offerings
or that
they they they they give birth to the
young ones
that's your interest rate
it's a better bank and going to the bank
and put money and
get eroded by inflation
so it's a better
investment opportunity
asset managers say more zimbabweans are
looking for ways to protect their
savings against inflation as the economy
struggles to rebound
i i think it will gain traction um
and we're very excited for it you know
we want this to be the thrust of
of starting to develop the national herd
and and get back into exporting of beef
and that they'll all just support the
local industry
for now at least cattle seem to be a
more stable currency than the local
currency one way of trying to preserve
investment value in a country where some
citizens have lost faith in conventional
methods harumatasa al jazeera norton
zimbabwe
from johannesburg i'm joined now by
yvonne mohango she's the managing
director and head of the africa research
economics at renaissance capital very
good to have you with us here um
inflation's now hit 800 percent in 2020
it's
131.7 percent in may how bad is this
going to get do you think
well i think there's certainly more
upside so yes we have seen inflation
creep up um we saw it uh come down last
year to around a 50 year year in the
middle of the year and then start to
pick up once again as the currency came
under pressure so the most recent print
is 192 for june and that reflects the
depreciation that the currency has been
coming under to your uh question um i
continue to see for further upside risk
uh to inflation and that's in part due
to quasi fiscal operations at the
central bank that is putting uh the
currency under pressure and in addition
to that of course the spike in commodity
prices okay let's talk about what the
central bank is doing why is that having
an impact on the currency
well we're in a situation whereby the
government is constrained in terms of
financing and that's related to the fact
that the country is officially under
debt distress which of course limits
their access to external financing um so
in a situation uh that presents itself
as uh currently whereby the government
is constrained on the fiscal front you
do find that the central bank is
stepping in and
having a quasi fiscal role essentially
which includes monetizing the budget
deficit that of course is adding to the
inflation pressures that we are seeing
also being blamed i believe at covert 19
and the ukraine war it's i can
understand what you're talking about in
terms of the central bank how do those
other two factors play into this
covert um as you can imagine
the government expenditure had to pick
up particularly on the health
side in terms of containing
the effect of the pandemic and also
providing measures to try and support
households and businesses that had been
impacted but impacted by the pandemic so
that of course pushed up spending and
now we have the um
the ukraine invasion which has of course
resulted in prices of fuel and food
including fertilizers picking up the
government of zimbabwe does subsidize
inputs into the agriculture sector
including fertilizer so that's putting
uh upward pressure on spending and as i
as i mentioned earlier the government is
constrained in terms of financing they
don't have the options of external
financing that other countries that are
more credit worthy to
so you do find that the central bank
does step in and monetizes the budget
deficit i want to ask you about more
about the the the role of the central
bank in this because it's being accused
of actually creating the situation in
the first place by essentially printing
lots of cash when it was being advised
by economists
not to do so is that a fair accusation
do you think
that is part of the problem
to be fair the
on the fiscal side at least the
authorities have tried to maintain a
very small deficit
because of concerns around financing uh
that particular budget deficit um but
given the constraints that not just
zimbabwe but several
african countries have faced during the
course of this pandemic it's this
central bank has had to step up in terms
of quasi fiscal um
activities in addition uh you have a
situation that that where by the
official currency um is over uh or
exchange rate is overvalued um sitting
at around 380
zimbabwean dollars to
the us dollar and then you compare that
to the parallel market exchange rate
which is at over 600 um to the u.s
dollar so that is also
part of the problem that um the
authorities are currently managing an
overvalued exchange rate um which is
putting pressure on the current the the
para market rate to depreciate
one of the things that we quite often
see in situations like this in other
countries around the world is that you
end up with two markets you
end up with one with the official
currency and of course you end up with
the black market in this case possibly
us dollars is that's what's happening in
zimbabwe
that's exactly what's happening and
unfortunately it does imply a transfer
subsidy so essentially what happens is
exporters who are asked to uh surrender
their proceeds at an overvalued rate as
well as those buying dollars on the
parliament market are subsidizing those
uh that can access dollars um at the
official market and that's the situation
we are seeing now um in zimbabwe
if the u.s dollar still has such a grip
in zimbabwe do you think that there's
any mileage in the country returning to
using the us dollar do you think that
the government of president emerson
molingo would actually be open to that
idea
i think we're already moving towards a
more dollarized zimbabwe uh similar to
what we had between 2009 and 2019
because essentially what's happening is
the zimbabwean dollars as you know a
currency is meant to be um a store value
a medium of exchange and units of
account and
if
for people to have confidence in the
currency that currency has to hold value
um and that's not the case currently in
in zimbabwe so yes um currency does tend
to depreciate over time due to inflation
but the rate at which the zimbabwe
dollar is um or is experiencing um
inflation is
resulting in such a huge loss of
confidence and you are seeing um
zimbabweans and residents seeking
alternative sources um um including um
um
these gold coins that have been
introduced in order to try and just hold
value in terms of assets
yvonne and margaret we appreciate your
time thank you very much indeed for
being with us
thank you for having me
and that is our show for this week but
remember you can get in touch with us
via twitter use the hashtag ajctc when
you do drop us a line or you can drop us
an email our address is counting the
cost at
aljazeera.net
but there's more for you online at
aljazeera.com
ctc that's going to take you straight to
our page which has got individual
reports links and entire episodes for
you to catch up on
that's it for this edition of counting
the cost i'm rob matheson from the whole
team thanks for joining us the news on
al jazeera is next
you